gençler merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz
yeni bir konuya başlıyoruz aslında
ortaokuldan bildiğiniz konulardan bir
tanesi nükleik asitler dna ve RNA'dan
bahsedeceğiz şu ana kadar gördüğünüz
birçok konu aslında size yeni anlatılan
konulardan mesela temel bileşenler işte
enzimler bunlar
belki böyle ortaokuldan bu tarafa
taşıyamadığınız bilgilerdi ya da
sınıflandırmayla alakalı şeyler gördünüz
ama bundan sonra böyle daha yakın
konular işlemeye başlayacağız işte
bunlardan bir tanesi geldi nükleik
asitler sonrasında ne olacak hücreyi
öğreteceğim size ve seneyi kapatacağız
tabii hala ısrarla hocam hayır biyoloji
çok zor bilmem ne falan hayır arkadaşlar
bakın bunlar bir süreç işi ben ne
diyorum size her şeyi zamana yayacağız
olabildiğince zamanı iyi kullanarak
genel tekrarlar yapacağız ve
öğretmenlerimize güveneceğiz bize ne
yapmamız gerektiğini söylüyorlarsa
yapacağız mesela bunlardan bir tanesi
sıkılmadan konu tekrar yapmak tabii bu
programı kendinize göre belirlemeniz
lazım yani mesela bazen öğrenciler diyor
ki hocam ne kadar sürede bir tekrar
yapmalıyım ama ben seni bilmiyorum ki
ben seni tanımıyorum senin ne kadar
yoğunlaştığını günde kaç saat ders
çalışmaya zaman ayırdığını kendine ne
kadar zaman ayırdığını bilmiyorum o
yüzden burada da en iyi cevap sende
olacak evet ne diyoruz hadi gelin
birlikte öğrenelim
nükleik asitler ifadesi nereden geliyor
nükleik çekirdek asit bildiğiniz asit
yani çekirdeğin içindeki asitler ifadesi
aslında bu çünkü ilk keşfeden bilim
insanları şunu görmüşler demişler ki
bunlar pH'ı düşürüyor demek ki burada
nükleik asitlerin pH'ı ile alakalı bir
yorum sorusu çıksa bazen içerisindeki o
saklı kelimeyi göremeyebiliyoruz başka
bir şeye odaklandığımız için ama pH'ı
düşürdüğü ortada nükleik asitler neden
kaynaklanıyor bakın buradaki fosfat
gruplarından kaynaklanıyor çünkü fosfat
grupları asidik özellik kazandırır ne
var yapılarında fosfat grubu var 5
karbonlu şeker yani pentoz ve azotlu
organik baz var pür pirimidin pür çift
halkalı demek pirimidin tek halkalı
demek pür Ankara gücü şöyle yazalım pür
Ankara gücü pirimidin Trabzonspor hatta
Urasili de RNA için yazalım sadece DNA
için konuşmuş olmayalım bakın Pürin
neydi çift halkalıydı yani burada
gördüğünüz gibi iki halka görüyorsunuz
demek ki bu ya adenin ya guanin bu
şekilde yaklaşacağız olaya o tek halka
olsaydı timin sitozin RNA isa urasil
peki hocam ben bunun DNA'ya mı ait
olduğunu RNA'ya mı ait olduğunu nereden
anlayacağım tabii ki öncelikle şekere
bakacaksın şeker deoksiribsa DNA'ya ait
ribozsa RNA'ya ait nükleik asitlere
baktığımızda DNA ve RNA açılımı ne
bunların deoksiribonükleik asit
ribonükleik asit yani deoksiriboz riboz
o zaman nükleik asitler neye göre
isimlendiriliyor şekere göre
yapılarındaki şeker
deoksiribo nükleik asit ribonükleik asit
bu tamam peki nükleik asitlerin yapı
taşı olan nükleotitler yani baz şeker
fosfattan meydana gelen bu nükleotitler
neye göre isimlendiriliyor hem
yapısındaki şekere hem de taşıdığı
azotlu organik baza göre mesela adenin
deoksiribonükleotidi timin
deoksiribonükleotidi ya da guanin
ribonükleotidi şeklinde arkadaşlar
nükleotitleri de şeker ve bazına göre
isimlendiririz bunları da küçük küçük
not olarak sağa sola kağıtlara alırsanız
sevinirim çünkü çok tatlı doğru yanlış
sorularıdır şık doldurma sorularıdır
tamam mı yani sadece bunu yazılı olarak
düşünmeyin ileride testlerde karşınıza
çıkacak aşağıdakilerden hangisi doğrudur
yanlıştır işte oradaki şıklardan
bahsediyorum devam edelim bakın nükleik
asitlerin nükleotit polimerleri olduğunu
söyledik yani binlerce on binlerce yüz
binlerce nükleotit yan yana gelerek
mesela DNA'yı meydana getiriyor bu da
ÖSYM'de küçükten büyüğe sıralaması
olarak karşımıza çıkıyor hatta ben
buraya şöyle bir yıldız atmak istiyorum
baz bazla şekeri birleştirdim
adı nükleozit oldu buna fosfatı
eklediğim zaman bunun adı nükleotit olur
hocam 3 tane nükleotit yan yana
geldiğinde kodon kodonlar geni gen
DNA'yı DNA da dikkat proteinle
birleşince neyi meydana getirir
kromozomu hep karşınıza çıkacak bir soru
söylüyorum şimdi DNA'nın yapısında ya da
RNA'nın yapısında protein olur mu olmaz
hocam çünkü bak çok basit bir şey
öğretiyorsun bize bir DNA ya da 1 RNA
nelerden meydana geliyor baz şeker
fosfat nerede amino asit yok hocam demek
ki DNA'nın ya da RNA'nın yapısında amino
asit protein olmaz bunların yapısında
peptit bağı olmaz ne var glikozit bağı
var ester bağı var ama peptit bağı olmaz
çok tatlı özellik sorusudur bunlar ama
kromozomun yapısında protein bulunur
çünkü DNA ve protein birleşince
kromozomları meydana getiriyor mesela
ökarjanlarda spesifik olarak insanlardan
bahsedelim histon proteinleri ki histon
proteinleri bazik proteinlerdir
içinizden tıp fakültesi diş hekimliği ya
da fen fakültesinin en baba
bölümlerinden biri olan moleküler
biyolojiyi öğrenecek olan arkadaşlar
oralara gidecek olan arkadaşlar için
söylüyorum şöyle bir ifade
öğreneceksiniz histon proteinleri
baziktir DNA asidiktir yani bir şekilde
bir nötralizasyon söz konusu oluyor
buradaki histon proteinler içerisinde de
çok karizmatik üç tane amino asit var
lizin arjinin ve histidin bunlar bazik
aminoasitlerdir hangi aminoasitler bazik
hangileri asitik hangileri nötr bunları
da ileride öğreneceksiniz o zamana
bırakalım ne işe yarıyor hocam bu
nükleik asitler mesela şuraya dikkat
edin hücrenin bilgi taşıyan molekülleri
özellikle protein sentez süreçlerini
yönlendirecekler bunlar ya da
yönetecekler mesela DNA emir verecek RNA
da bu emri yerine getirecek şeklinde
düşünebilirsiniz kalıtsal
özelliklerimizi belirliyor çünkü bizim
her şeyimiz protein işte saçımız göz
rengimiz organlarımız vesaire bunlar
protein yapılar ve bunlar aslında bizim
DNA'larımızın yansımaları o yüzden
birbirimize çok benzemiyoruz doğru mu
herkesin çünkü kendine özgü DNA'sı var
dolayısıyla bu DNA'lardaki bilgiye göre
bizim proteinlerimiz sentezlendiği için
biz birbirimizden farklıyız diyeceksiniz
bölünme büyüme gelişme ve enerji
dönüşümleri gibi hayati olayları
doğrudan ya da dolaylı olarak nükleik
asit kontrolünde gerçekleşir aslında ne
demek istiyor biliyor musunuz bu cümle
dna sonuçta bir emir verdiğinde ve emir
sonucunda bir protein oluştuğunda bu
protein belki bir enzim olacak belki bir
hormon olacak ve gidecek metabolizmada
kendine özgü bir işin gerçekleşmesini
sağlayacak belki de bu metabolik
solunumla alakalıdır ve enerji dönüşüm
metabolizmasında görev alacak ya da
belki yapıya katılacak hücre zarın
yapısına katılacak ya da bir enzim
olacak bir reaksiyonu katalizleyecek
gibi doğrudan ya da dolaylı mantığı
buradan geliyor bakın bu süreçlerde
kullanılan proteinlerin yapı ve
fonksiyonlarını belirleyen amino asit
dizileri nükleik asitlerden oluşan ve
gen olarak bilinen kalıtsal birimler
tarafından belirlenir bu ne demek hocam
bunun Türkçe meali ne yani sizin mesela
şurada bir gen bölgeniz var işte bu gen
bölgenizdeki nükleotit diziliminden siz
gideceksiniz bir RNA sentezi
yapacaksınız sonra bu RNA da gidecek
proteinin yapımında kullanılacak yani
dolayısıyla dikkat edin bunların
yapısındaki amino asitlerin dizileri
yani sıraları DNA'dan gelen şifreye göre
belirlenecek bunun türkçesi bu
arkadaşlar nükleotitler yapılarında
riboz şekeri bulundurduğunda
ribonükleotit söyledin hocam bunu zaten
deoksiriboz bulundurduğunda da
deoksiribonükleotit hocam hangisi daha
büyüktü riboz mu deoksiriboz mu riboz
daha büyük çünkü deoksiriboz deoksiriboz
bir oksijene eksik riboz demekti
hatırlatsana hocam onu c5h10 O4 bak
CNH2n ON kapalı formüne sahipti
monosakkaritler bu da 5 karbonlu
monosakarit ama bir tane oksijene eksik
deoksiriboz yani bir oksijene eksik
riboz demektir ribozda bu 5 deoksiriboz
da 4 oluyor peki nükleotitlerin
yapısında bulunan azotlu organik bazlar
pürin ve primidin olmak üzere iki çeşit
dedik pürinlere çift halkalılar
primidinlere tek halkalıları söyledik
pürinler bak Ankaragücü primidinler
Trabzonspor şuraya da bir Urfaspor'u
koyarsınız akılda kalıcıdır arkadaşlar
ankaragücü çift halkalı olacak azotlu
organik bazlar kimyasal yapıları
moleküler boyutları ve biyolojik rolleri
açısından belirgin farklılık gösteriyor
hocam söylediğini tekrar etmiş oluyorsun
bak primidin pürin ne yapmışsın pür çift
halkalı biraz daha karmaşık demiş pmidin
tek halkalı olacak peki geçtim
pirimidinleri şurada işaretleyelim şimdi
nükleotitler tabii baz artı şeker artı
fosfat dedik harika baz + şeker + fosfat
nükleotit nükleik asitlere de şöyle
yazalım nükleik asitlere de bunların
polimeridir dedik peki bu nükleotitler
nasıl yan yana geliyor hocam bak
karşılıklı geldiğinde aralara hidrojen
bağı gelebiliyor mesela DNA gibi ya da
RNA gibi T RNA gibi ama arka arkaya
dizilirken fosfodiester bağlarıyla bir
araya gelirler ve her bir bağın oluşumu
bir suyun açığa çıkmasına sebep olur bir
dehidrasyon tepkimesidir yani şimdi ben
bunu elimle çizeceğim merak etmeyin
buradaki karmaşıklığa sizi mahkum
etmeyeceğim sadece bunun kovalent bağ
olduğunu dehidrasyonla oluştuğunu
oluşurken su açığa çıktığını ve
nükleotitler arasında oluştuğunu bilelim
şimdilik kalsın boş bir sayfa açıp
çizeceğim siz de çizeceksiniz ve
öğreneceksiniz hep ne diyorum
einstein'ın çok güzel bir lafı var
basitçe anlatamıyorsan bilmiyorsun
demektir diye o yüzden önce en basit
haliyle anlatmaya çalışacağım biyolojik
sistemlerde deoksiribonükleik asit ile
ribonükleik asit olmak üzere yapısal ve
işlevsel olarak iki çeşit nükleik asit
bulunur dedik ve normal şartlar altında
neyi kesinlikle bilmem gerekiyor diye
bir soru sorsan bana ökaryot ve
prokaryot canlılardaki ayrımları bilmen
lazım yani ben eğer ökaryot bir
canlıysam ökaryot ne demek zarlı organel
ve çekirdek içeren hücre demek zarlı
organel ve çekirdek içeren prokaryot ise
zarlı organel ve çekirdek içermeyen
demek yani mesela prokaryot canlılar
kimdir diye sorsalar ne diyecektik
bakteri ve arkeler diyecektik peki
ökaryot canlılarda kim vardı protista
vardı bitki vardı mantar ve hayvan vardı
bu alemler vardı çok güzel şimdi ben
diyorum ki bunların yani bakteri ve
arkelerin madem çekirdeği ve zarlı
organeli yok o zaman bunun DNA'sı
sitoplazmada tamam peki ökaryotlara
baktığım zaman protista bitki mantar
hayvan bunların zarlı organeli ve
çekirdeği var doğru mu doğru hocam o
zaman DNA çekirdek içerisinde varsa
kloroplast içinde ve mitokondri
içerisinde olacak demek ki DNA
neredeymiş dna ökaryotlarda çekirdek
mitokondri varsa kloroplast içerisinde
mesela bende yok hocam kloroplast ben
fotosentez mi yapıyorum hayır güzel
yapısal olarak karşılaştırıldığında DNA
deoksiriboz RNA riboz içerir hocam 500
kere söyledik dersin başından beri
geçtim dna'da azotlu organik baz olarak
ATGC bulunurken RNA'da bakın burada bir
yanlışlık yapılmış şöyle yapalım a C G U
yani Urasil timinle yer değiştirmiş
tamam mı onu siz de düzeltebilirsiniz
oluyor insanlık hali hepimizin gözünden
kaçabiliyor burada da öğretmenlerimizin
gözünden kaçmış çok önemli değil
düzelttik adenin sitozin guanin urasil
diğer tarafta adenin timin guanin
sitozin var yani hocam bana öğretmenim
okulda şöyle bir soru sorsa dese ki
tamam bunların şekerlerinin ayrımını
yaptık dna'da deoksiriboz var dedik
rna'da riboz var dedik peki sıra şunda
baz ayrımını yapalım baz ayrımını nasıl
yapacağız hocam şöyle yapacağız işte
timin işte urasil rna'da urasil DNA'da
tim bulunur şeklinde bir cevap vereceğiz
dna çift sarmalı bir yapı oluştururken
RNA tek iplik olacak tamam dna çift
zincir ve sarmal yapı rna tek zincir tek
iplik olacak dna genetik bilgiyi depolar
ve aktarır rna ise bunu gider protein
sentezinde kullanır hocam bu konuyu
ilerleyen sınıflarda daha detaylı bir
şekilde öğreneceksin şu anda sadece
temel attığını unutma o yüzden hangisi
DNA'nın özelliği hangisi RNA'nın
özelliği şeklinde basit görevleri basit
özellikleri bilmeni istiyorum dna'nın
çift sarmal yapısında her iki iplikte
karşılıklı gelen nükleotlerin bazları
arasında hidrojen bağları kurulur yani
ne demek bu a ile T arasında G ile C
arasında ya da S de yazabilir sitozin
hidrojen bağları kurulur ne demiştim
aynı zincirde arka arkaya gelen
nükleotitler fosfodiester bağıyla
karşılıklı gelenler hidrojen bağıyla
bağlanır fosodiester bağını daha
göstermedim aklımda merak etme bu iki
iplik arasındaki eşleşmeler DNA'nın
sarmal yapısının oluşması ve bütünlüğün
korunmasında görevli çünkü bunlar
arasında bir çekim oluştuğunu düşünün
bazıları birbirini çekiyor çekiyor
çekiyor bir sarmal yapı oluşturuyor
arkadaşlar bir zincirdeki şimdi
söylediğimiz yere geri döndüm bir
zincirdeki A daima T ile G daima C ile
eşleşecek ve A ile T arasında ikili G
ile C arasında üçlü hidrojen bağı olacak
bak şimdi sana bir sır vereyim ax kadar
olsun TX kadar olsun G Y kadar C de Y
kadar olsun yani X + Y = X + Y
Ankaragücü E= Trabzonspor gördün mü o
yüzden dünya üzerindeki bütün canlılarda
A + G/ T + S'e eşit kabul edilir neden
çünkü A kadar T G kadar C ya da S var
bunun ikisini kullanayım ki gözünüz
alışsın çünkü bazı kaynaklar sitozine S
direk diyor bazıları İngilizce olduğu
için C'yi kullanıyor ama aslında doğrusu
Türkçesini kullanmak S'yi kullanmak
dolayısıyla her zaman pürin bazının
karşısına bir tane piramidin gelir çünkü
neden ankaragücü pürindi trabzonspor
piramidindi o yüzden her zaman pürin
karşısına piramidin gelecek kimde dna'da
tabii ki DNA ile ilgili konuşuyoruz bu
kural komplementer baz eşleşmesi
komplement tamamlayıcı demek
komplementer baz eşleşmesi olarak
adlandırılır çift sarmal DNA'daki a
bazlarının sayısı T bazlarının sayısına
G bazlarının sayısı ise her zaman C
bazlarının sayısına eşittir zaten burada
da onu söyledik x + Y = X + Y oluyor
dolayısıyla çift sarmal yapıdaki
DNA'daki toplam pürin sayısı toplam
piramidin sayısına eşit ankaragücü
pürindi hocam trabzonspor primidindi
birisi bana geldi dedi ki p bölü
primidin nedir aynı şeyleri yazıyorsun
hocam 1dir peki şöyle bir şey söylese
pür bölü toplam nükleotit sayısı hım
hocam toplam nükleotit sayısı mesela
hangi sembolü kullanalım şuna alfa
diyelim şuna beta diyelim şimdi pür
primidin doğru mu e hocam burada alfa
eşit beta tamam yaz bir kenara pürin +
primidinler bütün nükleotitler toplam
nükleotitleri vermiyor mu evet yani o
zaman pürin primidin toplam nükleotit
böyle olacak dolayısıyla ne kadar
pür şu şekilde bir oran çıkacak o zaman
bak şimdi ileride karşılaşıyan sorularla
ilgili sana basit bir matematik bir
nükleotitin içerisinde bir baz bir şeker
bir fosfat var doğru mu mesela geldi
bana dedi ki 1000 tane nükleotitten
oluşan bir DNA'da kaç tane fosfat var
1000 tane çünkü ne kadar nükleotit varsa
içerisinde o kadar fosfat olmalı 1000
tane nükleotit varsa kaç şeker var 1000
tane kaç baz var 1000 tane hocam peki
diyecek ki şimdi sana 1000 tane
nükleotitten oluşan bir DNA
molekülündeki şeker bölü toplam
nükleotit oranı 1 hocam 1000/1000
peki pürin bölü toplam şeker ha
diyeceksin ki bir dakika pür nükleotit
sayısının yarısı kadardır şeker ise
nükleotit kadardır sen diyorsun ki şeker
bölü pür hocam şeker x kadar pür x/2
kadar ters çevir çarp hop 2 ya da sana
pürin bölü şeker deseydi 1/2 derdin bu
da hani çok fazla karşına çıkacak
denklemlerden bir tanesi olacak
bitiriyorum sabredin bakın A ile T ikli
G ile S ya da G ile C arasında üçlü
hidrojen bağları var vitaminlere
geçmeyeceğim hemen boş bir sayfa
açıyorum sonra söylediklerimi de hızlı
bir şekilde tekrarlayacağım sana şimdi
bu fosfodester bağı nasıl oluşur bak
şimdi baz var
şöyle 5 karbonlu şeker bir de şurada
fosfat var hidrojen bağını koy bas ters
çeviriyorum sarmal yapıdan dolayı
şuraya şu şekilde çiziyorum bakın hadi
sembolik olarak şu şekilde yaptım şimdi
dikkat edin ben dedim ki baz şeker
fosfat bu bir nükleotit bu bir zincir bu
bir zincir karşılıklı zincirler arada
kimle birleştiriliyor hidrojen ama arka
arkaya gelen bazla şeker arasında ne
bağı vardı glikozit şekerle fosfat
arasında ne bağı vardı ester şimdi
buraya bakıyorum baz şeker şöyle bir
görsel var e bu da ester hocam bu da
glikozit ha o zaman bu böyle
gidecek öyleyse şu şekilde bir tane
nükleotit şu şekilde bir tane nükleotit
şöyle şöyle şöyle alt alta dizilecek
peki burada alt alta dizildiği sırada
bir sonraki nükleotitle nasıl bağlanacak
bak şöyle
bağlanacak şu şekilde fosfo ester ester
yani fosfo diester o zaman 2 nükleotit
varsa bir tane fosfodiester olur 3
nükleotit varsa 2 tane fosfodiester
çünkü neden 5 parmağım var 4 tane
boşluğum var şeklinde o zaman kaç tane
su çıkar sorusunu da öyle
cevaplayabilirsin 1000 nükleotitten
oluşan bir DNA molekülünün sentezinde
kaç tane su açığa çıkmıştır tabii ki
sentezi sıfırdan değil nükleotitlerden
başlatıyorum 500 nükleotit bu tarafta
500 tanesi bu taraftadır 499 su buradan
çıkar 499 su buradan çıkar yani 1000 -2
ama aynısını RNA için sorarsa öğretmenin
1000 tane nükleotten oluşan RNA
molekülünden kaç tane su açığa çıkar
hocam o tek zincirde 999 tane su açığa
çıkar şeklinde soruyu çözeceksin evet o
zaman hızlıca bir toparlayalım hocam DNA
RNA DNA sarmal yapılı hidrojen
bağlarıyla iplikleri birbirine
bağlanıyor ama tek bir zincir üzerinde
arka arkaya gelen nükleotitler birbirine
fosfodiyester bağıyla bağlanıyor hocam
DNA deoksiribonükleik asit RNA
ribonükleik asit DNA'nın yapısında
deoksiriboz RNA'nın yapısında riboz
şeker var dna'ya özgü baz timin RNA'ya
özgü baz urasildir dna için konuşacağım
şimdi purin primidin eşittir rna'da bu
eşitlik aranmaz çünkü tek zincir kaç
tane A kaç tane U kaç tane G kaç tane C
bilemem bilmiyorum ama mesela DNA ile
alakalı bana bir formül verdikleri zaman
mesela 50 tane adenin varsa 50 tane
timin vardır 100 tane guanin varsa 100
tane sitozin vardır a ile T arasında
ikili G ile S arasında üçlü hidrojen
bağı var ve ne dedim purin eşit primidin
olacak DNA için yani A + G/ T + S = 1
olacak bazen sizin kafanızı karıştırmak
için a + t/ G + S nedir diyorlar hocam o
türe özgüdür o oranı bilemeyiz tekrar
ediyorum Ankaragücü bölü Trabzonspor 1'e
eşit olacak ve son olarak nükleotit
polimeridir dna ve RNA nükleotitler baz
şeker fosfattan meydana gelir bazla
şeker arasında glikozit şekerle fosfat
arasında ester bağı bulunur ve
nükleotitler neye göre adlandırılır
yapılarındaki baz ve şekere göre
adlandırılır mesela adenin
deoksiribonükleotidi ya da adenin
ribonükleotiti mesela çok tatlı bir soru
sorar öğretmenin sana ileride der ki
"Hangisi DNA ve RNA'nın yapısında ortak
kullanılır?" Adenin bazı adenin
nükleotidi hocam adenin bazı neden çünkü
nükleotit dersen içinde şeker var
halbuki deoksiriboz riboz ayrımı yapman
lazım deoksiriboz DNA yapısında riboz
RNA yapısında ve hatırla monosakariti
c5h10 O4 deoksiriboz
c5h10o5 riboz olacak umarım
anlaşılmıştır